how have we found ourselves in this
position where people are queuing for
hours for fuel
we find ourselves in this position
because of a complete failure of the
government to lead and to plan ahead i
and other shadow cabinet colleagues
wrote to grant chaps back in july
highlighting these issues we got a very
short trip from grant shaps who wrote
back to us in the first week of august
saying in his words that he wouldn't be
using foreign labour to solve this
issue now the government says it wants
to
train up and i'm absolutely in favor of
training up hgv drivers but it hasn't
done that to a sufficient extent
nor has it until recently made a very
small concession on being able to bring
drivers in from abroad so this is a
catastrophic failure of leadership it
looks like we've ended up with petrol
running out the prime minister talking
about bringing the army and this is a
crisis of the government's own making um
hgv drivers being offered a three-month
contract pointless is what we're being
told by industry insiders what would
labour do
uh well we've already said that at this
stage you'd have to be looking at a far
larger number than that and you'd have
to be looking at more attractive and
longer visas and the number you would
need is what you would need to solve the
problem but also i i i asked other
shadow cabinet members asked months ago
about planning for this eventuality it's
this government that has ended up in
this situation through its chronic lack
of planning and sheer incompetence so
what number would you be looking at
well the gap at the moment is 100 000.
now i would much i would like to be in a
situation where we were able to do both
things having been training up drivers
to take up those positions and labor
would have been doing that for months
and months in a way this government
clearly isn't then because it's a crisis
you fill the gap by offering visas but
you have to be confident that the visas
that you are offering will attract
enough drivers so you've got to fill
that gap but the reason the government
is in such a desperate situation is it
hasn't been doing what it promised to do
both about training new hgv drivers but
also planning for the different
scenarios this autumn so what would the
visa look like if labor was in power
what i would be doing is taking advice
as to precisely what the visa would need
to be to attract the numbers the
government has got lots of different
modeling uh in front of it it will have
lots of advice as to
what the likely number of drivers you
will attract for particular conditions
is it has to i'm afraid look a bit more
than the 5000 and the three months that
is before it if we are to listen to what
uh most it seems across industry is
saying which is that's not going to work
you can't criticize the government for
saying three months is not it is not
enough if you if you don't have a figure
yourselves
well it's about choosing
what precisely it is that is going to
attract the number of drivers think that
might be i mean obviously you've got
your finger on the pulse obviously so
what what figure would labour come up
with
would be taking advice across industry
properly okay as to what best figure
what best that is okay well i i suppose
what i'm trying to get to you mr
mountain thomas this morning is okay
labour's not just sitting on their
bottoms thinking okay it's your problem
i'm guessing you're having those
conversations as well to try and be as
constructive as possible for the people
of great britain my question is as far
as labour is concerned having had all
those conversations as well what do you
think would be um something attractive
enough for european drivers to come to
the uk
but but but on the contrary k we haven't
had those conversations we wrote to
grant chaps in july about this asking
about conversations for what we could do
in terms of solving it we actually asked
grant chaps in july to refer this issue
of visas to the migration advisory
committee to give expert advice on this
and we were completely dismissed and
told that he wasn't going to use foreign
labour at all so it's no fault of ours
that we haven't entered into a
discussion and we haven't had access
that expert advice because that is
precisely what we asked to happen in
july we were just dismissed out of hand
and absolutely if grant chaps had come
back with a constructive response i
would have access to that advice from
the migration advisory committee and
would be in a position to start giving
you some more definitive positions it is
to the government shame that they
wouldn't even work with the opposition
when we raise the scale of this crisis
months in advance
government's right though isn't it that
um we don't need uh the army we're
looking at this petrol station in
manchester as we speak to you and there
are no queues anymore there's only a
finite amount of fuel that people can
put in their vehicles
and the problem will resolve itself
by the end of the week
well it's remarkably complacent if the
government is just sat there assuming
what is going to happen in a few days
and i do worry the government isn't
taking responsibility we have a prime
minister on the one hand was saying
don't panic on the other he was saying
that he needed to bring the army in so i
think you have to look at the mixed
messaging from the government and as
always with this government when it hits
a crisis it's always apparently somebody
else's fault rather than their failure
to grip it and to plan for different
scenarios in advance problems uh not in
manchester this morning as we can see
certainly at that fuel station but there
are in many other parts of the country
should emergency and essential workers
be able to jump the queue
i think we do need to look at that
absolutely but again
you're putting that question to me k and
then on the other the government is
saying the problem is going to resolve
itself so yet again you get into mixed
messaging but what an appalling position
the government finds itself in we are
here in 2021 we are rationing petrol
we have a government that is threatening
to bring the army in and we have a
supply crisis
all of which the government has been
warned about the government should have
listened about and through thorough
incompetence it now finds itself in this
quite awful position uh this september
okay you have those pesky ear pieces
they're really irritating aren't they
hopefully you can still um hear me as
i'm chatting to you um nick so are you
saying that that the um emergency
workers should be able to jump the queue
a bit like two decades ago when when
labour had a similar issue getting
petrol to the pumps and there were
special passes that were issued for
emergency workers to be able to get fuel
ahead of others
well in crisis situations you've clearly
got to prioritize key workers it isn't
as if you know that that's a contested
definition i mean the government has
used that key worker definition
throughout the pandemic i'm thinking for
example in the lockdowns when you know
key workers were still allowed to go out
to work so the government has all that
on the books already as to who is a key
worker and of course if you're
prioritizing keeping the country running
that's what you have to do but goodness
me
prioritizing keeping the country running
with a government that is rationing
petrol this is quite an appalling
situation that this government has now
reached and there's no one to blame for
it apart from them and their
incompetence you're going to tell a
conference that labour should be um
tough on crime what should what would
labour do about those protesters on the
m25
in terms of the protesters on the m25 of
course i am very passionate about
tackling climate change however i do not
believe that unlawful protest is the way
to go about it and i've been very clear
that i support action that the police
the operational decisions police are
taking on the on the front line i also
support the use of injunctions because
the problem is that when police do
arrest people for for breaking the law
which they are breaking the law they can
only stay in custody for a limited
period and they can come back so i think
the use of injunctions is also very
important but the underlying issue of
climate change absolutely i and labour
are very passionate about tackling
um andy mcdonald my goodness me um
former uh colleague of yours in the
shadow cabinet what's all that about
well look uh people have resigned on
points of principle before and i always
respect people who take that decision
andy is a friend of mine who will
continue to be a friend of mine
and i have great respect for the work
he's done on the employment rights paper
where we will end appalling practices
like fire and rehire we will give people
employment rights from day one but i
must say in terms of the motion that's
before conference today the leadership
is very happy for delegates to back it
we are very committed to a minimum wage
of at least 10 pounds an hour but it is
the responsible thing as we get closer
to the election to look at rate of
inflation rate of wages the wider
economic situation for the precise
figure that we will put before the
country at the next general election
but we are fighting for working people
now whether it is in terms of a minimum
wage of at least 10 pound which by the
way would be a 12 percent increase in
wages for many people whether it's in
terms of cancelling the universal credit
cut whether it's speaking against the
government's plans to hike national
insurance which are frankly attacks on
working people as well because i wish
andy well on the back benches
yeah but why did he have to do it at
party conference we broke the news to
rachel rave tamara cohen did that um
yesterday she looked visibly shocked at
the discussion at the news i should say
i mean why wash your dirty linen in
public labor seems to do this year after
year you've got open goals left right
and center and you and you're washing
your dirty laundry in public
well look only only andy can answer the
question as to why he chose on that
particular day to resign it's always a
difficult decision to make but what i'm
seeing at this conference is rule
changes from kiyostama to ensure that
the party will now be able to look
outwards people said that those rule
changes wouldn't get through they told
here to back off but he showed strong
leadership and got them through we're
now in a situation where rachel reeve
sat out her store yesterday i'll be
doing that today on labour's priority on
neighborhood policing making clear that
if there is trouble on your street labor
will make sure that somebody is there
and setting out my plans to put police
hubs neighborhood prevention teams to
tackle anti-social behavior across the
country and tomorrow you will hear from
kiyostama with his vision for the
country as well